اهلا بكم شهدت مدن ليبيه عده ابرزها
طرابلس بنغازي وصراطه الزاويه مظاهرات
نددت بانعقاد مجلس النواب في مدينه طبرق
في اقصى شرق البلاد
وقدم نواب ليبيون طعنا لدى المحكمه العليا
في دستوريه الاجراءات الصادره عن اجتماع
اعضاء من البرلمان في طبرق نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر ل نناقشه في محورنا ما هي انعكاسات
اجتماع البرلمان في طبرق على الواقع
السياسي في
ليبيا وما هو تاثير الهزائم التي تلقتها
قوات اللواء حفتر من ثور ليبيا على
العمليه السياسيه في
البلاد
يتنامى في ليبيا حرك شعبي رافض لعقد جلسات
البرلمان الجديد في مدينه طبرق الليبيه
المدينه التي عرفت بتاييد للواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر مظاهرات خرجت في عده مدن ليبيه
تطالب بتطبيق الاعلان الدستوري الذي يحدد
مكان انعقاد البرلمان في العاصمه طرابلس
ثم في مدينه بنغازي حرك شعبي ياتي بعد
سلسله من الهزائم تلقتها قوات الواء حفتر
على ايدي الثور تقرير احمد
جرار على غير ما اراد المجتمعون هنا في
طبرق جاءت ردود الفعل المتتاليه على
محاولتهم فرض واقع سياسي جديد يتجاوز حسب
ما يرى منتقدوه ما اتفق عليه الليبيون في
اعلانهم الدستوري بالسيناريو التونسي اذ
يتصاعد في المشهد الليبي حراك شعبي رافض
لعقد جلسات مجلس النواب في المدينه التي
تستخدمها القوات المواليه للواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر كمنطلق لطائراتها التي تقصف
خصومه في بنغازي وهي المدينه التي كان
يفترض ان تتم فيها عمليه نقل السلطه
المظاهرات التي خرجت في عده مدن ابرزها
طرابلس وبنغازي ومصراته والزاويه لم تكتفي
بالتشكيك في شرعيه قرارات المجلس الجديد
بل اعلنت تاييدها لما تعتبره شرعيه ثوريه
تمثلها قوات حفظ امن واستقرار ليبيا في
العاصمه طرابلس وقوات مجلس شورى الثوار في
بنغازي باعتبار انها تواجه معسكرا يسعى
للانقلاب على منجزات ثوره الساب عشر من
فبراير ويضم في صفوفه ما تسميه بقيادات
الثوره المضاده لكن الذين اجتمعوا في طبرق
متسلحين بشرعيه سياسيه افرزتها صناديق
الاقتراع في الانتخابات الاخيره مصرون على
ما يبدو على مواصله مسارهم خصوصا في ظل
التاييد الذي حظيت به خطوتهم من قبل جهات
امميه ف فضلا عن دعم الجامعه العربيه
ومنظمه التعاون
الاسلامي لكن الهزائم الميدانيه التي منيت
بها القوات المؤيده لهذا المسار في كل من
طرابلس وبنغازي قد تدفع التحالف الذي
يحتضنها الى التعجيل بطلب التدخل الخارجي
وهو طلب سبق ان طرحه في واشنطن رئيس حكومه
تسيير الاعمال عبد الله الثني كما انه
ياتي في وقت تتصاعد فيه الاشارات القادمه
من مصر حول استعدادها التدخل العسكري في
ليبيا حفاظا على ما تسميه امنها القومي
وهو تعبير بدئ باستخدامه مؤخرا في القاهره
بعد فشل خياراتها الاخرى على ما يبدو
والتي كان ابرزها دعم قوات حفتر بطريقه
غير مباشره بين من يتمنى في ليبيا تكرار
نموذج الجار التونسي والوصول بالبلاد الى
حاله تصالح سياسي وبين من يراهن على تكرار
نموذج الجار المصري ودفع البلاد الى قبضه
العسكر يبقى خوف الكثيرين من انزل ق
البلاد اكثر فاكثر نحو السيناريو الذي سبق
ان مر به الجار الجزائري عندما دخلت
البلاد في حاله من الاقتتال الداخلي استمر
نحو عقد
كامل موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
ليبيا الباحث السياسي صلاح البكوش عبر
الهاتف من بنغازي السنوسي بسيكري مدير
المركز الليبي للبحوث والتنميه ومن طبرق
توفيق الشيبي عضو المؤتمر الوطني السابق
عن تبرق مرحبا بكم جميعا اذا واضح سيد
الشهيبي وابدا معك ان قاعده الانتقاد
قاعده الرفض لهذا لهذه البرقيه ان صح
التعبير او التوجه البرقيه و قد يكون
مصطلح جديد يعني في الحياه السياسيه
الليبيه تتسع هذه القائده خرجت من
الصالونات الان في الشارع هناك تعبيرات
في الشارع عن الرفض لعقد هذا المؤتمر
لماذا امام كل ذلك مازال هناك اصرار على
تبرق لعقد اجتماعات مجلس النواب
الجديد اجل بعد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والصلاه والسلام على اشرف الانبياء وال
المرسلين والترحيب بك وبضيوفك الكرام وبكل
مشاهدي قناه الجزيره اعتقد ان عندما نقول
هناك رفض واسع علينا ان نحدد معنى هذا
الرفض عندما بعض المدن اصدرت رفضا ونوابها
موجودون في طبرق يعني
هنا نتحدث عن اوراق وكتابه واختام لاثنين
او ثلاثه يمثلون مجلس يمثلون منظمه المم
المدني يختمون ورقه ويقولون نحن نرفض
اجتمع نواب الامه متمثلين في اكثر من 160
عضوا في طبرق وبالتالي نحن نتحدث هنا عن
اغلبيه 160 من حوالي 186 تم انتخابهم عبر
صناديق الاقتراع نتحدث عن هنا امر قد حسن
سياسيا وقانونيا هذا هذا من ناحيه من
ناحيه اخرى عندما نتحدث عن جلبه لماذا هذه
الجلبه لماذا على ان تكون هناك ولو جلسه
بسيطه في طرابلس طبرق هي الوطن طبرق التي
انتفضت يوم 17 فبراير تحديدا قبل العديد
من المدن الاخرى ولم تزايد على احد البرق
التي كانت الثغر الشرقي للبلاد ايام
الثوره وكانت شرين الثوره لماذا ه مزايده
طبر مدينه ليبيه مثلها مثل غيرها
وقانونه يمكن معلش يعني مع ان هذا الجدل
اتخذ لبوس سياسي واضح ولكن في الاساس هو
قانوني يعني جدل قانوني وبيص
هم يقولون الاعلان الدستوري ينص على ذلك
لماذا الخروج على
النص لا لا لماذا الخروج على النص لان
دستوري فيه صراحه ان مقر الرئيسي لمجلس
النواب بنغازي وله ان ينعقد في اي مدينه
اخرى يعني ركز وله ان ينعقد وعندما تخرج
ورقه من قبل وزير الداخليه يقول لا يمكن
عقد الجلسه في طرابلس وبنغازي وعندما تخرج
ورقه من مديريه امن طرابلس تقول لا يمكن
عقد الجلسه في طرابلس اما مديريه امن
بنغازي فقد سواها من يسمون انفسهم مجلس وث
شور الثوار الذي من بينهم تنظيم القاعده
في ليبيا وهم انصار الشريعه سو سووا
مديريه ام بنغازي بالارض ط في باي عقل
يمكن ان ت جلسه في مدينتين تقام فيها حرب
ولماذا هذا الرفض في طبر لماذا يعني هذا
الرفض الكبير جدا رغم انه قد اجتمع فيها
اكثر من 160 ضبا الجدل القانوني سوف تحسمه
الامر المحكمه الدستوريه وانا شخصيا من
باب الطلاع ومن باب خبره سابقه في المؤتمر
مطن العام اقول لك ان الامر محسوم مسبقا
الدستوري قال ولها ان تنعقد في اي مكان
اخر طيب سيد البسكري هل فعلا الامر
محسوم مسبقا يعني الا ترى ذلك خروج صريح
على
الاعلان الدستوريه وربما يجلب مخاطر على
الحياه السياسيه
الليبيه يعني هذا هو الماذق الليبي الراهن
ان النخبه السياسيه سواء كانت في مفر في
المؤتمر الوطني العام او اليوم البرلمان
الجديد تاخذ ب
سياسه كسر العظم
او ما تراه مناسب او يجاري تصورها في
استخدام مصطلح دستوري او لا دستوري
واغلبيه او ليست اغلبيه انا يعني اعقب على
الاستاذ توفيق بانه عندما تكون ازمه شديده
ووضع مازوم جدا لا ينفع فيها الارقام لغه
الارقام ليست
كافيه لا ينبغي ان نقول 160 عضو
وتنتهي المساله انت في وضع نزوم
وبالمناسبه من
يؤيدون انعقاد البرلمان في طبرق عارضوا
بشده على سبيل المثال اغلبيه
دستوريه في قرار المؤتمر الوطني العام
بالتمديد وانا شخصيا انا ضد التمديد لكن
التمديد من داخل المؤتمر الوطني العامس
التوفيق كان حاضر تم اقراره باغلبيه
دستوريه وفق الاعلان الدستوري المعارضه
الشديده قالت بان هذه الاغلبيه تجاوزت
الاعلان الدستوري نحن الان نقلب المشهد
لماذا نلجا الى هذا التصعيد والى هذا
التازيم ولا نذهب الى التفاوض العقلاني
والمنطقي
لماذا ندرك بان على سبيل المثال ذهبنا الى
طبر قد يؤزم المشهد السياسي وهو مازوم انا
مع الدكتور مع الاستاذ توفيق بانها فعلا
100 60 برلماني موجودين لكن عندما يكون ال
160 برم برلماني موجودين سبب ل تزم كما
راينا بان 124 عضو مؤتمر وطني اقر التمديد
بقرار هذا ازم المشهد وكان متازم في ذلك
الوقت عندما تكون الاغلبيه سبب التازيم
لماذا لا نذهب الى الحكمه ونقول لنترك
طبرك لانها قد تفسر وقد فسرت بانها مدينه
الكرامه فسرت من قبل المعارضين وكان هذا
حديثا احد احد البرلمانيين قال
بوضوح لن اذهب هل كان صادقا في ذلك او لا
ولكنه قيل لن اذهب الى طبرق لان طبرق
مدينه تخرج منها طائرات تقصف بنغازي اذا
هناك تازين في الذهاب الى طبط لماذا لم
نذهب الى مدينه اخرى لي بنغا سؤال جد سؤ
وتكن الجفره على سبيل المثال سال سؤال جيد
سريتا هذا لم يفكر فيه القاده
السياسيون انقل هذا السؤال دعني انقل هذا
السؤال الى السيد اصلاح البكوش يعني لماذا
لا تتاح مدينه اخرى ليبيه لماذا يعني انت
او لا احد تبرق او او لاحد لماذا او كيف
نفهم كيف نفهم حقيقه التمسك والاصرار على
تبرق هل هو موقف سياسي تعبيره سياسيه
ما لا يا سيدي انا في تصوري ان الجدال
الدستوري او القانوني حول مكان انعقاد
المؤتمر الاعلان الدستوري يقول بصراحه ان
مكان المؤتمر هو مدينه بنغازي وخلافا لما
يقوله السيد شهيبي عندما تنعقد في بنغازي
يمكنك انذاك ان تقرر نقل البرلمان الى طبر
او الى البيضا او اي مكان ولكن هناك
مجموعه صغيره اختطفت هذا القرار وقررت
الذهاب الى طبرق مخالفه للاعلان الدستوري
اما القضيه في ليبيا في تصوري مع اهميه
هذه اتباع الاعلان الدستوري والقواعد
الدستوريه لما في ذلك
فائده على الليبيين جميعا في المستقبل
اعتقد ان الج ان ان القضيه هي اكبر من
المكان واكبر من هذا الجدال الدستوري
القضيه يا سيدي هو ان هناك محاوله لقلب
نظام الحكم في ليبيا من نظام ي مؤسس على
مبادئ 17 فبراير الى نظام جديد او ما
اسميه جماهيريه ثانيه ربما بدون القدافي
والشله المحيطه به ولكنه نفس النظام وهذا
ما تبين من تقرير ديوان المحاسبه وهيئه
الرقابه حول مده الحكومه الماضيه وهذا ما
يتبين الان عندما ترى تصريح
جهبيه النظام السابقين
كاحمرار
لاستعاده السلطه وان ما يحدث في طرابلس
اذا صمد القعقاع والصواعق هذا جزء من
خطتهم للعوده الى السلطه ا طيب اعود الى
السيد الشيبي يعني طالما ان هناك جدل
قانوني اي ربما لاحقا اخذ كما ذكرت منذ
قليل
لبوث سياسي لماذا لا لا يقع الحسم في في
المساله يعني بكل بساطه والانتقال الى
مكان اخر في في ليبيا يعني لماذا الاصرار
على
التمسك بتبرق ثم ان هناك طعون قدمت الى
المحكمه الاداريه سيد الشيبي في هذا
الموضوع ل يفترض ان يترك الامر للقضاء حتى
يقول كلمته فيه وفي الاثناء تجمد
الخطوه
اجل هو هو من الناحيه الدستوريه كان على
المفترض ان يكون يوم 4 اغسطس كانت كان في
كل الاحوال يج تكون الجلسه الاولى لن
البرلمان الجديد وهذا امر دستوري حيث نص
قانون الانتخابات انه في مده اقصاها
اسبوعين من النتائج النهائيه تعقد الجلسه
الاولى هذا امر هذا امر موجود وهذا بقانون
الانتخابات التي على اثر ينتخب البرلمان
الجديد هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى
المشكله التس في المدينه طبرق بلغت بانها
سوف تستضيف الجلسه الاولى يوم الاربعاء اي
قبل ال خمسه ايام فقط من يوم عه فبالتالي
لم يكن من المقرر ان تكون طبرق ولكن بعد
ان تاكد انه لن يكون لا طرابلس ولا بنغازي
تم اختيار طبرق الامر يعني هذا هذا من
ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى من يتكلم عن عن عن عن
هذا الامر المحكمه الدستوريه موجوده
الدائره الدستوريه عفوا في المحكمه العليا
موجوده وهي التي سوف تفصل في هذا الامر
ولكن بكل الاحوال هناك فقه برلماني ان
هناك برلمانيين منتخبين واندل والدليل على
ذلك انه كثيرون حاولوا افشال وصول عدد
كبير من الاعضاء لماذا ان كان هناك
يعني امر غير دستوري لماذا وصل هذا العدد
الكبير من الاعضاء بطرق يعني بمسافات
بعيده جدا بدا ياتم مباشره هذا شيء الشيء
الاخر المشكله هنا بدات الاتهامات تتجاوز
حتى المد قنا الجزيره هي الادرى من غيرها
قنا الجزيره عندما دخلت دخلت اول المدن في
دخلت لطبق وواكبت الثوره بشكل جيد عن طريق
طبق وهي ت جيدا مت يعني العالم كله يعرف
متى انطلقت في هذه الثوره الان يتحدثون عن
ازلام ومحمد ق بالحق للاسف الشديد هناك
كتائب اسست بعد 20 عش في ليبيا الان اصبحت
كتائب ثوار بعد 20 ع بعد مقتل القذافي لان
تحار معين وكتائب شاركت في تحرير طرابلس
اصبحت الان كتائب ازلان لانها اصبحت في صف
اخر هذا الاصطفاف يجب ان ينهيه امر سياسي
واضح الامر السياسي هنا محليا واقليميا
ودوليا حسن لا يزال المحكمه الدستوريه
وانا شخصيا مازلت اقول انه مكتوب المقر
الرئيسي بنغازي ولم يكن ولم يقال الانعقاد
الاول او الجلسه الاولى او اول اجتماع مع
المقر الرئيسي بنغازي وله ان ينعقد في اي
مكان اخر طيب ستبقى معنا طبعا سيد توفيق
الشيبي نتوقف فقط عند فاصل قصير نناقش
بعدها الحرك الشعبي في ليبيا ضد عقد
اجتماع البرلمان الجديد في مدينه طبرق
فنرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد اذا في هذه الحلقه
التي نناقش فيها الحرك الشعبي في ليبيا ضد
عقد اجتماع البرلماني الجديد في مدينه
طبرق اعود مع السيد سنوسي البسكري السيد
البسكري هناك ربما ما هو اكثر حساسيه
واكثر خطوره من ذلك ال الان هناك تلويح
بعدم الاعتراف باي قرارات قد تصدر عن هذا
البرلمان ال الجديد الا يشكل ذلك ربما
عمليه نسف للحياه التشريعيه ول هذذه
النافذه الانفراج التي انفتحت في الازمه
الليبيه نعم يعني انا في تقديري بان هناك
سيناريو متوقع في في مسار العمليه
السياسيه بعد انتخاب البرمان وانعقادها في
طبر وهو انه هناك احتمال سيناريو تصعيدي
بمعنى البرلمان ينحو منحى على سبيل المثال
تجريم عمليه فجر ليبيا وما حدث في بنغازي
وتجريم ورفض نتائجها
بطرق مختلفه على سبيل المثال ان يختار
رئيس حكومه ضد قوات الدروع اقرب على سبيل
المثال
الى عمليه الكرامه ان يختار رئيس اركان
اقرب الى عمليه الكرامه ان حدث هذا
فالسالفا
على الثوره ستفسر من قبل قوات الدروع
والعديد من الثوار بانها فعلا انقلاب على
على الثوره وبالتالي خاصه
سيد البسكري خاصه وان الواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر توجه منذ ايام بكلمه مسجله
يعني توجه يعني خاطب فيها البرلمان الجديد
وقال لابد له ان يتخذ قرارات هامه و
مصيريه هل هل في ذلك تلميح لما كنت
تقوله انا اتمنى انا يعني مؤكد انه اللواء
حطق فيت لكن اتمنى هذا لا يحدث لانه
سيدخلنا في مازق لا يمكن ان نخرج مننا
فتره قريبه ان اجه البرلمان الى التصعيد
وترك خيار التفاوض خيار الحوار فض
الاشتباكات الراهنه وقف حمام الدم الخروج
الى الى توافق باليه معينه
بطريقه لا ينحد فها الى اي طرف هذا برلمان
الدوله كلها وانا عندي ملاحظه على كلام
الاستاذ صلاح بانه ان قلنا بان البرلمان
الراهن يمثل السلطه التشريعيه الجمريه
الثانيه فهذا اي
فيه ايدانه لاختيار الشعب البرلمان 160
عضو قد لا نتفق مع العديد منهم قد نتحفظ
على بعض قراراتهم لكن هذا 160 عضو
يمثلوننا يمثلون ليبيا اخطاوا في المشاركه
في تازم المشهد من خلال الذهاب الى طبق
وكان بالامكان ان نس الى الازمه الراحله
لكن اي ان نتهم انه البرلمان هذا يمثل
وجهه سياسيه ل جماهيريه ثانيه هذا فيه
خطاب للشعب بانه اقرب الى الجماهيريه
الثانيه منه الى 17 فبراير هذا ما فهمتها
ويستطيع الاستذ صلاح ان يصحح لكن اعود
لاقول بانه البرلمان باي دافع كان انا لا
اقول بان الدوافع انقلابيه باي دافع كان
اتجه الى التصعيد باتجاه قوات
الدروع باي طريقه كما قلت اختياره لرئيس
حكما رئيس اركان او وقفه للميزانيه الخاصه
بالدروع هذا سيزم المشهد ان قوات الدروع
انا عندي ملاحظه بسيطه و تسمح لي الثوار
والمسلحون ق الدروع شرعيتهم الرئيسيه هي
شرعيه الثوره وتناهوا تماه مع المؤتمر
الوطني العام واعتبروه الجهاز التشريعي
المقبول لانه وافق ما راوه مكتسبات ثوره
17 فبراير الان يفسرون وقد راينا هذا في
بيان المجلس الاعلى للثوار يفسرون اتجاه
البرلمان وافراز الاخير بانه ثوره مضاده
لو استمر البرلمان في اتخاذ قرارات يراها
الثوار وقوات الدروع معاديه فان انهم
سيرفضون نتائج البرلمان كلها وربما
سيذهبون الى حاله قد تكون خطيره وهي فرض
حاله الطوا السيطره على مؤسسات حيويه
وبالتالي قد ندخل في ساريو اكثر تازم سيد
صلاح البكوش ه هل انت تذهب الى هذا الراي
هل هل ليبيا فعلا او الافق السياسي الليبي
بدا ينفتح على ما يسمى بثوره مضاده وب
مساعي انقلابيه
بالطبع هناك ثوره
المضاده المعركه الجاريه الان هي معركه
كان يجب ان نخوضها في 2011 ولكن الطرف
الاخر المضاد للثوره اجلها حتى يحارب يوما
اخر ما يحدث الان
في البرق وما يقوله السيد توفيق الشهيبي
هو انتقائي جدا لقد اسقطوا المؤتمر الوطني
العام المؤتمر الوطني العام بالرغم او في
وجه مذكره قانونيه واضحه من الامم المتحده
تقول ان المؤتمر الوطني ليس لا تنتهي
ولايته ولكنهم اسقطو واصروا على تشكيل
لجنه فبراير واصروا على ان ينفذ المؤتمر
الوطني جميع توصيات لجنه فبراير الان اول
قرار يتخذه هذا البرلمان هو الغاء ما اقرت
هو لجنه فبراير والذي نقل السلطات
التنفيذيه الى رئيس مرتقب الان غيروا هذا
الاعلان الدستوري ورجعوا السلطات
التنفيذيه الى البرلمان حتى يمكن
ان يتقاسموا الكعكه ويغرق الكثير من
النواب اما ما يحدث الان اعتقد ان ما
يقوله السيد بسيكري عن السيناريو الاول هو
الاغلب اوفر حظا وانا اع اعتقد اننا سنصل
الى نقطه ان نعلن فيها
نحن هذا الطرف الذي يؤيد ثوره 17 فبراير
نعلن ما اعلنه الطرف الاخر منذ شهور عندما
اعلن المؤتمر لا يمثلنا نحن سنعلن ان هذا
البرلمان لا لا يمثلنا ويقبع البرلمان في
طبرق او في اي مكان اخر وسيصبح برلمانا
ليس ذو معنى ا انه ليس له اي قوه على ال
سي سيد الشيبي هل هل سمعت هذا يعني هل
انتم واعون فعلا بمخاطر
ان يقول الناس او ياتي يوم ما يقول الناس
هذا البرلمان لا يمثلنا خاصه وان هذا
البرم البرلمان مطروح عليه قضايا هامه
ومصيره ماذا انتم فاعلون اذا اذا كان
الناس لن يتقبلوها
ويرفضها نعم نعم هو هو السيد صلاح بكوشي
يصر على تضل ال العام اولا سطات لم تنتقل
لرئيس دوله لان المؤتمر الوطني العام لم
يقر رئيس دوله على الاطلاق وترك هذا في يد
البرلمان القادم والبرلمان قادم قال الى
حين انتخاب رئيس دوله فبالتالي لم ينقل
لنفسه شيء بل حاول توزيعها بين بين سلطات
للحكومه السياديه فقط للحكومه وللبرلمان
اما المؤتمر الوطني العام قال بالحرف
الواحد انه يترك الخيار الانتخابي المباشر
ام غير مباشر لرئيس الدوله للبرلمان
القادم هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى بماان
الامر وصل الى اصطفاف فبراير وغير فبراير
اذكره ان هنا نائ تعرضت للتهديد ووصلت
الان شقيقها وهو شهيد وكان قائد ثوار
زليتن في الثوره فبالتالي هنا لا يمكن
مزايده بالثوره كذلك بدي البرق خرجت قبل
مدن اخرى كثيره فبالتالي هنا عندما ناتي
للمزايده بالثوره هنا هذه الطامه التي
رجعتنا ل كثيرا ان كل يزي باسم الثوره وكل
يتحد باسم الثوره قوات فجر ليبيا هي كل ما
تحصلت عليه في طرابلس هو تدمير المطار ما
اكثر ذلك فقط شهداء من الطرفين او قتلى من
الطرفين وزياده احتقان بين الطرفين في
الثوره هو مصرات والزنتان لا داعي للتص
امور نقول فجر ليبيا نقول وقعهم زنتان
انضم معهم مدن جبل الغرب الذي انتفض مبكرا
مصرات الذي انتفضت مبكرا والان يتقاتل
الثوار السابقون ايضا قوات درع شرقا لا
يمكن ان تتجاوز بنغازي بعشرات الكيلومترات
فلديها من المدن الثائره شرقا وغربا من
المدن السائره اكد التي سوف تمنع ذلك
فبالتالي هنا اتاد ب انفسهم اردنا ان نعود
ل هذه التسميه مجدك س معلش لانه الوقت
يعني تقريبا وصلنا الى نهايته فقط سؤال
خاطف للسيد البيك في اقل من دقيقه يعني ما
هو الحل يعني هل هناك وصفه الان قد تكون
جاهزه
للحل يعني بسيط يا استاذ حبيب بسيط رشد
رشد رشد لدى اعضاء البرلمان الان في ان
ينتبهوا بان اي قرار قد يقابل بتصعيد خطير
ورشد لدى القوى السياسيه خارج البرلمان
ولدى القوات بان تدرك بانه ليبيا داخله
على على على منزلق خطير ال الشقاق ما بين
قوه على الارض وبرلمان منتخب هذه هذا مازق
خطير وبالتالي رشد لعقلنا التنازل قليلا
والمعيار الرئيسي الذي يجب ان ي عند
الجميع البرلمان
وثوار هو مك 17 واضج الى ت اشكرك سيد
السنوسي انا اسف حتى الصوت يعني اصبح غير
واضح تماما شكرا لك سيد سنوسي البسكري اذا
مدير المركز ليبي للبحوث والتنميه اشكر
السيد اذا اصلاح بكوش الباحث السياسي ومن
طبرق توفيق الشيبي عضو المؤتمر الوطني
السبق بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في ما وراء
خبر جديد دمتم
بخير يا